so there are also new questions over
whether florida counties are correctly
tabulating coronavirus deaths
fox 35 orlando reporter daniel lama has
this story
danielle well hey there lisa yeah this
uh is coming up because we were speaking
with the orange county health officer
yesterday
about some of the numbers regarding
coronavirus deaths and we had noticed
that two people in their 20s
had died from covid and so we asked him
if there were any underlying conditions
involved
and one of the answers really surprised
us he told us that one person
actually died in a motorcycle accident
and he told us that that had gone into
the coveted numbers and he had asked the
state to remove that number
and when asked if it had actually been
removed or cleared from that data he
said he didn't think so he wasn't sure
but he was going to double check on that
and so that's when we started asking
questions here
and what exactly do can you just
elaborate a little bit more on what you
found and what questions you asked
right so we were told that it was a man
in his 20s who
did test positive for coronavirus but
had died because he was in a motorcycle
accident and so then today we've been
trying to follow up on this
to figure out if this is still currently
in the state data and so
the orange county health officers his
office is telling that they are still
working to try and confirm that to see
if that death was cleared from the
system
we also reached out to the medical
examiner
here in orange county because those
folks have to certify
the covid deaths and he told us that
that death would not be qualified as a
coronavirus death his exact quote was we
only ascribe
covet deaths if covid is the cause of
death or contributed to the cause of
death
and we also have of course reached out
to the state department of health
they tell us that their health
departments
covid 19 death is determined if coven 19
is
listed as the immediate or underlying
cause of death or listed as one of the
significant conditions
contributing to the death so of course a
lot of questions about how a motorcycle
accident
may have ended up in that state data and
you know a lot is riding on these
numbers and people want to make sure
that these are accurate
there are big decisions schools
governments making decisions looking at
the data
so that's why we're asking these
questions when we hear something like
this
no you're 100 i mean we're making public
health decisions we're making decisions
that have economic consequences as well
mental health consequences
so danielle stay on it we appreciate
your reporting
thank you